wanted something broad and but also
specific to gwen and so
that's what i did she didn't know i was
going to do that and so i surprised her
with the song and we actually just
recorded
the song here in nashville yesterday
blake shelton revealing he wrote a song
for gwen stefani
for their wedding i don't know what or
when we're going to do something with it
but it's something that i wanted to have
a recording of
no matter what you know blake revealed
the sweet music news during an interview
with storm warren
on sirius xm's the highway explaining
that the song was actually hard to nail
down
at first i started trying to write a
song because that's kind of the opposite
of of what she would have expected me to
do because i
i'm to the point where i just don't
write that many songs anymore it's just
like pulling teeth for me and
it's something she's she's always on my
case about it
of course blake says the tune turned
into something more special than he
could have
imagined that's why we wear these rings
you know this is
we're together now and i feel that way
about the song it's like
it is a uh you know for me uh
uh something that i want people to hear
and
and know and because i'm i'm proud to be
married
to gwen and so proud of that song i was
only trying to impress gwen
the reveal of blake's song for gwen
comes just days after the pair took the
stage together at cma's summer jam
[Applause]
sometimes i just feel like i'm in a
dream gwen was blake's special guest on
stage they perform their duet
happy anywhere
of course blake and gwen tied the knot
on july 3 in oklahoma
at the time a source opened up to e.t
about the picture-perfect wedding
quote they've both been through a lot
and deserve to find each other
they were meant to be a couple in every
[Music]
way